back on the job site worker ondrea's
geekus is focused on a more immediate
problem trash Evo will generate over
five thousand tons of trash collecting
it is the job of the trash hauler to
copy the guys I'm gonna really get this
place into shape and get it looking good
so it's livable someone's got to do it
so I just take the initiative and do it
what about this stuff here can I get
this part now I've learned to see what
trash what what they might reuse and if
I don't know I usually find the foreman
of a different trade and ask them is can
I throw this out it's okay I try to get
permission from somebody before you do
that just in case I'm you don't want to
step on any toes to achieve
certification from the US Green Building
Council 75% of this trash needs to do
recycle
some of it like scrap wood is sorted on
site
the rest of it will go to a diversion
center where any recyclable material
will be sorted out
six months before the deadline Evo is
hit with a painful setback a rare la
rainstorm hits during the weekend
water leaked through open holes on the
unfinished top deck and ran down through
the building into units that had already
been finished then you look at the
drywall down here it's coming out right
underneath here hey Bill Jerry hey I'm
in 1208 in the bathroom there's a water
coming out of the electrical outlet and
I just let you know I'm gonna need some
help
a group from ISEC the cabinet and
finishing contractor arrived to inspect
the damage because I wanted if the
exterior skin they weren't able to
complete it because of the man lived
here that there's some relationship
between the league the exterior skin
that being sealed off and the man life I
think is this all have to be replaced it
says I mean it's it's not like we can
salvage a section and you know you know
my mold issues and all that stuff it's
all going to
carpenter Darryl Slater works into the
night to replace floorboard that he
installed just a few weeks earlier I've
done the whole building every room and
I'm going crazy
this stuff here is MDF it's medium
density fiberboard and sometimes it'll
because of the weather the moisture
they'll Bend up it'll move it'll keep it
even painted correctly it'll even come
off the wall it'll be filled with
moisture and water and it really wrecks
and blows it up we're really races to
come back and replace what's messed up
soon as the water gets in there and it
just cuz of the rain here last week yeah
I guess there's a room down on them four
or five that got flooded and all the
cabinets and all the everything's got to
be replaced the flooring everything is
over the rain it leaked in through
somewhere and just totally messed up
though huh